Okay.
So last time we saw the jeopardy approach
to solving the shredding or equation,
which is to take the answer and
find out what the problem was.
And we saw that for a constant potential.
You've got a sine wave,
you could choose any length of sine wave
you wanted, any wave period you wanted.
It just turned out to be different
energies and it had a relationship between
the wavelength and the energy,
the kinetic energy or the total energy.
In that case,
uh,
and we saw an exponential is, um, uh,
corresponds to negative kinetic energy,
which not very many
people in the class liked.
And not very many people ever like it,
but suck it up because that's the way
kinetic energy is for small particles.
If you don't like to call
it kinetic energy because
you're so wedded to the fact
that that for big things,
it's one half MV squared,
then just consider it the difference
between total energy and potential energy.
Okay. But anyhow, it's
kinetic energy. Okay.
So we've looked at the jeopardy approach
to start with the answer and get the
question,
but we'd lot,
we'd rather do it the other direction
to start with the problem and find out
what the answer is. And you can
do that by guessing the energy.
If you have a sufficiently simple system
that is one particle in one dimension,
and this is a great way to get the
idea of what's special about quantum
mechanics, make it as simple as possible.
And then we'll go to realistic systems.
Okay, so we can rearrange
the Schrodinger equation.
Remember this is the Schrodinger equation.
Hci Equals East side divide through by
Sy and split the HCI oversight part into
the potential energy part V,
which is a nothing,
it's given to you and the
and the kinetic energy part,
which is a negative constant that involves
the inverse mass times the curvature
of Psi over Psi.
So it has to do with the shape of sy.
And remember if you
multiply side by a constant,
you multiply the curvature
by the same constant.
So the kinetic energy stays the same.
So it's only what we say the shape,
not really the amplitude because that
scales with the, with the curvature.
Okay,
but now we can rearrange
this this way so we can,
we have a formula here for the
curvature of Psi right now,
if you have a formula for the curvature,
if you know how a curve is going to
change how a line is going to change its
curvature,
then you have a recipe for drawing it.
If you know how to start,
if you start with a certain
height and a certain slope,
suppose you know that and you
know the curvature at that point,
then you know if you take a
little step in that direction,
what the next slope is going to be.
Okay?
Because that's how curved it is and if
you recalculate and know the curvature at
that point,
then you know what the curvature at the
next point is going to be in the next
and the next and the next.
Then you can use this to just
draw a curve that's bound to,
to satisfy the Schrodinger equation
because you're using the Schrodinger
equation to generate it.
Does everybody see this?
This is really important. You want me
to say it again? Or you've got it now,
if you have a formula for the curvature,
that's how fast the slope is changing.
And if you know the initial height
and the initial slope, right,
then if you know the
direction of the slope,
you know where the next
point's going to be. Okay?
So you go to that just to make a tiny.
Now this gets a problem in a computer.
If the thing is really going like
this and you take a finite step,
the slope will have changed during your
step and you won't get it just right.
So you'll have to take
smaller and smaller steps.
So that doesn't change during the step.
Genuine.
Can't hear it very well. Yeah. Curvatures,
the second driven. Yeah.
Uh, we'll get to that.
But if you had the initial
slope and the initial height,
then you use the formula for the
curvature to trace out the curve.
Everybody got that now.
Okay, so that's great. And,
and it would be tedious
to do this by hand,
but that's what this little program,
urban meets goldilocks does,
is start the curve and draw
it out according to what
if you know everything else
in the equation. Okay? So,
and remember it curves away from zero
when the potential energy is greater than
the total energy and it curves towards
zero when the potential energy is less
than the total energy,
right?
So the potential energy being greater
than the total energy is a bad situation
intuitively.
Right?
It means the kinetic energy is negative
and it curves away from the baseline.
And what's bad about that or dangerous
about that? Yeah. Okay. Kevin?
Pardon me?
Yeah,
it'll keep going until it gets to
infinity if it's curving away. Okay.
So that, and that's not allowed.
It has to not go to infinity. Okay?
So now do we know everything
else? Well, we know am the mass.
We know the constant c
and the V is given to us.
The potential energy is
changes with position, right?
But we know how it changes with position.
It's cool ohms law typically,
or we can do some other law if we want to.
So this recipe,
then you know everything,
everything on the right except the
total energy sigh you don't care about,
because you can scale it, right? You can
make it anything you want. Call it one.
Okay, then we can double it. Or if we
want to or whatever. So side, we know em,
we know. See We know v we
know we're going to guess e.
So that means if we know the initial
slope and for the problems we work on,
the initial slope will be
zero. And you'll see why. Okay?
Then we can use this formula
to trace out the curve.
And that's what the computer does for you.
So people were worried last night
about math. Don't worry about math,
you don't let the computer calculate
how these slopes change and so on.
Right? All you have to do is
think about the curvature. Okay?
So you just have to think about the graph.
Okay?
So we're going to talk now about nodes
and quantification in one dimension.
Using this program,
[inaudible] meets Goldie locks.
And there's a problem set for Monday
as you know that, where are you, uh,
where you do this?
And the answers are on the Wiki,
but don't look at them before you've given
it a good try. Okay, so let's, let's,
there, there are simpler things to start
with like a constant potential energy or
running into a wall or into
a pillow, more like, but the,
but the,
uh,
the harmonic oscillator or Hooke's
law is a very popular one to do.
So we're going to do that.
Okay.
So here we're looking at the potential
energy as a function of distance and also
on the side.
So you'll see the distance goes from
zero to two and a half fox drums and the
potential energy and the potential
energy goes from zero to a hundred
kilocalories per mole. You can change
that if you want to on the computer. Okay?
And the horizontal black line
is a completely different plot.
It's a plot of PSI. That's what, that's
the plot on top of this, when the,
where we're going to trace
out the wave function. Okay?
And that's zero of the wave function.
Here's zero of energy,
okay.
And the reason we put them on top of one
another is so that it's easy to see the
influence of one on the other
of the wave function on the,
on the potential energy and vice versa.
And because there are functions of the
same thing, what cy? A function of,
what's that?
A function of its function of the
position position of what the one particle
we're talking about.
Okay.
And the potential energy is also
a function of the position. Okay?
So the way we're going to do
this then is to guess an energy.
Let the computer trace out this
curve and see whether it's okay.
What will tell us whether it's okay,
how will we know if it's okay?
It's got to be continuous,
that we're not going to have a problem
with that because the computer's tracing
it out this way.
It's not going to be just continuous w
but the main thing is that it doesn't
diverge and it doesn't go to infinity.
Okay.
So let's just guess 21 kilocalories
per wall. Why not? Okay.
Now you can already tell
me something about what the
curve is going to look like.
Notice that at those two distances,
between these two distances,
the total energy is higher
than the potential energy.
What's the curve going to
look like in that region?
If the kinetic kinetic energy
is going to be positive, right?
What will the curve look like?
Pat?
Can't hear very well.
It's going to spike up in between
those two lives. It made me go up.
It may go down. Yeah. Pardon me. Uh,
it's not,
would it be a sign curve?
Does anybody think that wouldn't be a
curve by not Russell when the potential
is, that's when the potential is
constant. It's not constant through here.
Right?
So it won't be an exact sine
curve if this isn't very high.
It might be close to a sine curve cause
it's sort of constant dish, right?
If this is a very small distance,
but what characteristic
must have said Sydney,
it'll curve towards zero. So it might,
it'll, it'll look something like this.
Always. It's curving and going
up and down, maybe going high,
but it's always curving.
To go back toward the baseline,
it's never going to go to infinity.
Okay.
Now there is a problem because
if you go the other way,
the rest of the graph,
the kinetic energy is negative because
the potential is higher than the total.
So in that region,
there's great danger that the line is
going to go to infinity because it's going
to be curving away from the baseline.
Okay.
Now,
how could you possibly avoid that?
How could you have it such that the
curvature divided by the value of the way
you function gets very big and the
curvature away from the baseline,
but still it doesn't go to infinity.
How can the kinetic energy
be big and negative?
The curvature divided by
the value is enormous,
but it doesn't go to infinity.
How can that be?
Pardon me?
Bound.
No, it's not a question about, I mean,
this thing is that the particle,
if it has this total energy is bounded,
right?
It can't go all the way to the left to
the right. That's true enough. Okay.
But that's not the,
that's not the secret of how the wave
function avoids going to infinity.
Yeah.
Pardon me.
Uh,
we can't make what a constant.
Okay,
Russell,
but, but you say very
little curvature, but,
but the kinetic energy is enormous.
The curvature divided by the value of
the wave function has to be enormous,
Mike.
Ah, if the value of the wave
function is almost zero,
then you can have an
enormous burden. Uh, yeah.
Then you're going to have a tiny
numerator, hardly any curvature at all.
And still the quotient can be big,
right?
The kinetic energy can be
enormous and negative, right?
If the denominator is near zero.
So that means that if
you're in those red regions,
you know what the wave function has to
look like. What does it have to look like?
It has to get down near zero and stay
there so that it doesn't have the
curvature that will enough
curvature to pull it away.
So it's got to look like that on
the left. Right? Cause out here,
you know that parabolas going way up.
It's an enormous curvature
divided by wave function.
But if the wave function
is essentially zero,
still the curvature can
be essentially zero. Okay.
And the same on the right. So we know
that the curve is going to look like this,
something like that.
Okay.
And all we have to do is connect
the pieces. Okay? So let's try it.
We guessed 21 kilocalories per mole.
This we did in our head
just by thinking about it.
But let's let the program
do it and start at the left.
And now do you see why it has to
start with with a zero slope why?
It has to start with zero slope.
Because if it's out in this region
and does it has a finite slope or a,
an appreciable slope and it's
curving away, you're in trouble.
Okay? Cause it's going to go to
infinity. Okay, so here, here's,
so we're going to use Arabic
meets Goldilocks, this program,
and we're going to start it here.
It goes the curve and there there's
the part where the kinetic energy is
negative,
right?
It hasn't gone to infinity because it
started low enough and with low enough
slope out of the left.
Okay?
Now what's going to happen
when it crosses that line?
Hi.
Now the curvature is going to be toward
the baseline as we guessed it would be.
So I like that.
And now what's
going to happen
now it's going to start curving
away from the base line again.
Aw,
you don't win them. All right. Okay.
Now did we have too much energy
or too little energy here?
Notice that. What? What did
we want it to do on the right?
On the left is where we started.
That looks great,
but on the right we're having trouble.
What do you need to do in the middle
in order for it to behave? Okay?
On the right,
it has to not curve so
much toward the baseline.
Does everybody see what I'm saying?
If it curved less than it could join
that other line we had originally.
Okay, so we'll give it a little less
energy. Let's try 20 that's too hot.
Okay. Too much energy. Okay, so well
guess 20 kilocalories from all. Okay,
here we go. Start out almost exactly
the same. It's nearly the same energy,
so it doesn't surprise you that it looks
about the same and then it's going to
curve in here. The way we expected, but
a little bit less than it did before.
All right,
so now we're on the way to success.
Yeah.
So what was that one
to coal and what do you need?
Someplace in between these.
There's going to be one.
That's right.
Okay,
so it's between 20 and 21 now.
Should we guess halfway between 20 and
21 is that the reasonable thing to do?
Which original guests was better?
Which guests was better
originally and why?
The red one or the blue one.
Which guests was better?
Why was the red one
better close to baseline?
It lasted longer before it
went to infinity, so it's,
it'll be closer to the red,
the blue,
and if you fiddle around,
and that's what I want you to do because
this is the way I think it gets into
your head, is by guessing
numbers and saying, where
should I make the next guests?
And so on. After you've done
this a certain number of times,
but enough times that it really gets into
your bones and your brain right after
you've done it enough times,
then you can use the function that says
solve and it will do that guessing game
for you. But do it yourself
at the beginning. Okay.
And it turns out that after you've done
that, you get 20.74 Dadadadadada. Dot.
I like a lot of decimal points,
decimal positions,
and you get that one just right.
Okay.
So that's the only math you need to do.
Is it too hot or too or just right.
Okay.
And do you have to know why it has to
be that way because of this curvature
thing? Okay, so there we
are. There we have it.
20.74 kilocalories per mole
is a satisfactory energy
and it comes with this wave
function, whatever. That's good for. Okay.
But the energy is what we were looking at.
What energies are allowed
for this system now,
could there be a lower energy
allowed for this system?
Could you imagine a less
curved wave function that
would also have this property
of not going to infinity?
Can somebody guess what
it would look like, nick?
Ah,
it could just go up and then come back
to the baseline has to come back to the
baseline but it could just go up rather
than curbing so much in the middle.
Okay, so we guess the lower one,
could there be a lower energy sy? Yes,
indeed. There could be one at
4.15 it's actually one four,
nine something or other.
Right.
Do a lot of decimal points and there
it is exactly what nick expected.
Okay, so you got this. Could
there be a still lower one
rolling?
Not In between.
Could there we one lower than the blue.
Can you imagine a way to get
it even lower than the blue?
Even lower curvature than the blue?
Yeah.
Angela [inaudible] like the one can't
hear very well if the blue one is going up
and we weren't going down. Oh, there
could be an upside down blew one.
Absolutely true.
There could be an upside down blue one,
but it's the same thing because it's
the blue one multiplied by minus one.
Remember you can multiply it by any number
and it's still the same thing. Right,
so that's exactly the same energy.
It's not a different wave function.
It's just multiplied by a constant,
but you're right that
that also does the trick,
but it turns out to be the same thing.
Can you imagine anything
lower in energy than this?
Impossible because of it. Have it had
less curve curvature in the middle.
It bound to go to infinity right
when it got back in the other region.
Okay,
so that's the blue is the lowest one now
could there be one in between these two?
Yeah.
How it looks like. How
could you do it? Yeah,
Kevin,
one eight
oh one peak above and one
below. All right. You could,
could there be an energy in between?
Yes, indeed. There could be that one
right now.
Could there be others in between?
What happens as you add curvature,
you have these nodes.
I is where the wave function is zero.
It's not a node out here
where it's almost zero.
A node is when it's exactly zero and it
has to be zero because it's going from
being positive to be negative.
Obviously it has to go through a zero
out here and out there. It's very, very,
very small, but it's not
zero. That's not a node.
A node is where it's zero
because it's changing side. Okay.
Now nodes are related to energy.
Why
notice that? The lowest energy when
blue had no node, the next one,
the purple had one node.
The next one,
the bio or whatever color it is,
had had two nodes.
Why is there that relationship?
They are inflection points,
but why are,
why do they get higher and energy
when you have more nodes? Sam?
Uh,
say it in terms of energy.
Some people would say frequency
is energy. That's, that's true.
But I want you to say it in terms of,
we've been talking about
how do you get more nodes?
Yeah.
Absolute value with curvature.
Yeah. If the curvature gets bigger,
you get more nodes and
curvature is the energy,
the kinetic energy, right? So
more curvature, more nodes.
More energy or more energy,
more curvature,
more nodes. So we have zero
nodes, one node to those.
Those are the lowest three you can get.
And then there would be, uh, three nodes,
four nodes, five node, six notes,
had as many nodes as you want. Okay?
Now this is great. You can do all
sorts of neat tricks for Monday.
And what I want you to do with this
program is just the fiddle around with it
and make discoveries for yourself.
And I'll show you some of the
kinds of discoveries that,
that you can do in the next slides here.
Uh,
but I warn you that if you have
more dimensions or more particles,
right,
things quickly become impossible.
The only thing you can do this particular
approach with is one particle in one
dimension.
Because if you have more,
if you have more,
then you don't know which curvature to
change. You know, the curvature Bimbo,
or it's a sum of a bunch of curvatures.
And knowing the kinetic energy,
the difference between total and potential
doesn't tell you which curvature to
change. If there's only one, then you
know that that's the one you have to do.
So it's going to be a heck of a lot of
work to do this for more complicated
systems, right? And that's
not our purpose. Now,
our purpose is to understand how quantum
mechanics works with this simple system.
But the question is, is it going to
be worth our effort to learn out how,
learn how it works if we're unable
to do anything with it. What are our,
another way of putting it is,
what's the reward?
What are we going to get out of this?
Is it worth spending some time on? Well,
here's the reward for science,
finding Psi,
the knowledge of everything,
okay?
For example, you know what?
Energies are allowed to assist them.
You know what the structures can be.
You know how it behaves dynamically,
how it moves.
You know how bonds work. That's
what we're really after. Remember?
And you know what makes for reactivity?
So there's a pretty good pot
of gold at the end of this.
So fasten your seat belts and,
and put your nose to the grindstone
and all sorts of metaphors.
And we'll do this for the
next couple of weeks. Okay.
First we'll look at allowed
energies and structure. Okay?
Now of course we already did this,
right? No nodes, one node, two nodes,
but what were the energies
that were allowed? Okay,
so here's a whole bunch of them,
right? No nodes. One node to node,
three nodes up to seven nodes, or
is it seven? Yeah, seven nodes.
Now here are the energies.
4.15 12.44 20.74 29.04 37.34 do
you see any pattern to the energies
you might read the title if
you have trouble seeing right,
they're evenly spaced right
after the first one, right?
They're evenly spaced. How about
the first one compared with zero?
How high is the first one?
If you know this spacing,
it's half the first one above zero is
half as big as the spacing of the others,
right?
So the energy is some constant and that
constant is what a 8.8 0.3 roughly times
an integer minus a half.
Why do you have the integers
cause nodes come in into jurors.
You can't have half a node right at zero
nodes, one, two, three, four and so on.
Okay,
so that's pretty great.
We know for four springs or
harmonic oscillators or uh,
an Adam stuck on a bond
as long as the potential,
it doesn't vibrate so much that the
potential deviates from looking like a
parabola right at the bottom of the curve,
it looks like a parabola.
So this is the way Adam should
behave when they're attached by bonds
approximately.
Okay?
Now remember that Doggerel poem from
1926 we only wish that we could glean an
inkling of what cy could mean.
What have we used? Cy Four so far
we used it.
It's not going to infinity to find
out when we guessed the energy, right?
It was just a tool for telling us
whether we had the right energy.
But does cy really mean something
besides just being a handy tool for this
purpose?
And it was later,
six months later in 1926 that it was
suggested what the meaning of it was.
And it was in this paper by Max born
that this side doesn't mean anything but
size squared is probability density or
proportional to probability density if
you scale it right.
Remember,
you can scale side by n multiplied by any
number you want. If you scale it right,
it is the probability density
of the particle. Now, here's,
here's what he wrote in German.
And what it says is if one,
when she wishes to translate
this result into physical terms,
only one interpretation as possible
size signifies the probability of the
structure.
But there's a footnote there cause he
made a mistake and he corrected it after
the thing was already set in type,
right?
So we've put a footnote
here, which, which me,
which says a correction added,
improve more careful consideration shows
that the probability is proportional to
the square of sy.
Why couldn't it be quite good in the
probability be proportional to cy?
Because cy can be negative. You
can't have a negative. Well,
that's one reason there, there were
other reasons too. And, uh, he,
I dunno how embarrassed he was by this,
but anyhow,
but since nobody else
knew what side was at all,
I think he could be proud
nonetheless. Right? But anyhow,
it's the square of side not site itself
that gives probability density. Now,
uh,
late six months later,
a Albert Einstein wrote a letter to
mocks born where he said something you've
probably heard, but an inner voice tells
me that this is not the real thing.
Theory yields a great deal,
but it brings us no nearer to
the secret of the old one anyway,
I'm convinced that he does not play
dice, right? So it's not probabilities.
There's this fundamental determinism,
Einstein things,
but it turned out that in this
respect, Einstein was wrong, right?
It is probability.
Now it's not probability,
it's probability density.
And we have to think a little bit
about this and we can think of it in by
analogy with mass density.
Suppose you had a flask and that had
mercury in water and oil in it, right?
And that you're going to ask the question
if the total mass in the flask is one
kilogram,
what fraction of that or how much weight
is exactly one centimeter from the
bottom?
How many are,
what fraction of the total do you think
would be exactly one centimeter from the
bottom?
Anybody got a guess?
5% 1% half a percent 10% 12% three
there'll be this big auction,
right?
Do I hear higher than 12% do I
hear lower than 12% who's bidding?
Yup. What do you say? Zero.
Why zero? Well, obviously
it has to do different.
Different heights would have
different densities, right?
So there'd be a lot more in mercury than
it would if I drew the line in oil or
in or in water. Right? But you say zero y
right?
A plane or align or a dot
doesn't have any volume,
right? You need a volume. It's zero.
You're right. You need a volume.
You have to multiply density,
grams per cubic centimeter by volume.
How many cubic centimeters
in order to get mass?
And the same is true of some so that in
this case the real question would be how
much is between one centimeter and 1.01
centimeters or something like that.
You could ask that question but you can't
say how much is exactly one centimeter.
So you have to multiply by
volume multiplied density
by volume to get the amount
right and this that and so psi
squared is probability density.
It's how it's how probable it
is to be in a a small volume,
a unit volume around
the point in question.
So you go to some point in question
square, cy, find the density,
multiply it by the volume over which sy
is constant because it doesn't very real
rapidly.
So he choose a really small one multiply
and that's the probability of being in
that little block.
Okay?
Now remember we said you could multiply,
you could scale side by any constant you
wanted to even minus one or minus Pi or
whatever. Okay? What
is there a good value,
a preferred value to scale it by?
You could scale it by such a number
than what it squared and you multiply by
volume over every place,
right?
Sum up all these little boxes. You
get one. Why do you want to get one?
Cause the total probability is
one that it's someplace, right?
So that's,
that process is called normalization.
We don't usually worry about that,
right?
We usually just take whatever numbers
we want that's convenient to plot on the
graph and know that we have to scale it
such that if we want to calculate actual
probability density, that's
going to some the one. Okay,
so here's an example where above we showed
two of these curves and below we show
squares of those not properly
scaled together. Together.
There's I think a little more
area in the red than in the blue.
Although maybe I'm bad.
They should have the same area if
the thing were normalized. Okay,
so that shows what it is. Now there's
an interesting thing about that.
If you have a pendulum or a thing on a
spring and it's going back and forth,
where does it spend most of its time?
At the extremes, right? Because
it's going so slow there, right?
In the blue one,
where does it spend most of its time?
Where does it spend most of its time?
Where is it most dense?
If it's the blue wave function,
the lowest wave function,
the zero node wave function,
obviously it spends its time in
the middle, not at the extremes.
But notice if you get to the seventh
wave function, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, the seventh
wave functions are going
to have seven humps, okay?
Then it's most profitable at the extremes,
right?
And as it gets, as it gets,
as you get higher and higher,
it gets more and more
focused at the extremes.
And that's why when you get to
something that's really heavy,
it behaves the way you expect the
pendulum or a thing on a spring to behave.
This is not normalized,
but notice something else that's really
valuable here are really crucial,
which is that this line is
where the potential and the
total or the same for the
red curve,
right?
So here is zero kinetic energy in here.
The kinetic energy is positive.
Out here it's negative.
And the thing can be out here,
right?
So the thing exists in a region
of negative kinetic energy.
There's nothing special about that.
Okay?
It's just that that's the way things work.
Kinetic energy can be negative.
And in the case of the blue one,
here was the point where
the kinetic energy was zero.
And all of this out here is probability
in a region of negative kinetic energy.
Now what did we do it
with the Morse potential?
Notice if we look at the first
one with a morse potential,
it looks the same as it would in a,
in a Hooke's law harmonic oscillator.
Does that surprise you?
No, because the potential looks
that way pretty much. Right?
But as you go higher and higher
and get here to whatever that is,
the 12th or something like that,
you can see that it's very different
and it's spending a lot of time far out.
It's shifting.
It's average to the right.
But that doesn't surprise because the
well moves out to the, to the right,
right? As you move up in the Morse
potential as you move to higher energy,
uh,
because low kinetic energy,
which is what you have as you move
to the right means low curvature.
Why does that make it high probability?
Because as long as you have high
curvature over wave function,
whenever the wave function peaks up,
it gets pulled down again. Right?
It can't stay up. But if you have very
low curvature toward the baseline,
very low kinetic energy,
then it could go up and you don't mind.
Okay.
Cause the Connecticut,
you don't need much curvature when
the wave function is big. Okay.
So it's like that.
And then out in here it's pretty
much like an exponential decay.
Does that surprise you
Kate? You look like it didn't
surprise you. Why not? When do you,
when do you expect the wave
function to be an exponential decay
under what condition
can't hear very well is constantly.
Oh, when the potential energy
is constant and, and what else?
To be exponential stop sign
wave is also constantly,
right.
What makes an exponential
rather than a sine wave?
Yeah. Ah, the kinetic energy is
negative. Potential is higher than total,
but that's exactly the case on the right,
right.
Because there's the potential,
there is the total and the kinetic
energy is going down. It's negative.
The difference between the two.
Okay.
Now here are a whole bunch
of these for, for the, uh,
harmonic costs for the Morse potential.
How does it look different
from the hook's law?
Does the spacing of energies look the
same as it did and Hooke's law? Again,
it's zero nodes, one, two, three, four
and so on. But how is it different?
Yeah.
Ah, the spacing gets closer
as you go up. So real bonds,
which have a potential that looks
more like this than like a spring.
We'll have their energy levels get closer
as you get more and more vibrational
energy.
Okay.
They're not evenly spaced
as they are for Hooke's law,
the energy increases along
with a number of nodes.
The well widens more than it
would for Hooke's law parabola.
So the wavelengths become longer.
Those nodes are spaced over
a bigger distance. Right.
And the energies are lower than expected
for Hooke's law because you don't have
as much curvature.
You have the same number of nodes.
The like the 18th level has the same
number of nodes that would in Hooke's law,
but they're spaced over a wider distance.
Right.
So there's less curvature so the
energy doesn't go up as much.
Okay. Now this is interesting.
Look, if you have the blue energy
right now, the wave function looks
like this, it's no longer bounded.
Does it surprise you that
the wave function goes on
out to infinity when the, uh,
when the total energy is higher than the,
than that potential energy if the right,
no,
it means you have enough energy to break
the bond so the particle could just
keep going.
Okay.
Now what does this look
like in this region?
It looks like it does in a Hooke's law
or something like that, more or less.
What does it look like out at the right?
It's a sine wave.
Why Sam? Does that surprise you?
That looks like a sine wave.
The potential is constant,
effectively constant out there
and lower than the total.
So it's a constant,
it's about a sine wave because you have
a constant positive kinetic energy when
the total energy is above
that dissociation limit.
So there's the potential,
there's the total,
and now the kinetic energy is
positive and about constant,
so it's approximately
a sine wave. Okay. Now,
Coolum beach potential is
a more complicated one.
The reason it's complicated is
the energy goes to infinity.
When our becomes zero,
when the positive and the negative
are on top of one another,
it becomes infinitely favorable.
So it's hard to do this numerically
and the program will screw up.
Sometimes when you try to
do cool omic potential,
but here's a,
and it's one dimensional and that it turns
out curiously enough that this system
is simpler in three dimensions
than in one dimension for Coolum.
Big potential. Don't worry about
the technical aspects of that.
But at any rate,
this is using the program for that.
And you can see that that the
lowest that you have very,
very high curvature when you get near
zero because you have such high kinetic
energy when the particles get
very close to one another and the,
because the urban program is
approximate taking finite steps,
you get in trouble often. Okay. But
anyhow, you get the idea that again,
as you get a higher energy, you get, uh,
you get waves that spread out and they
spread out a lot for the same reason they
did in Morse potential. Although
here we're using a much lighter mass.
We're using an electron,
right?
But it spreads out much more because
the well spreads out so much.
Okay. So higher levels spread way
out. And now the sequence of energies,
here's the lowest,
the next and the next.
They have a big spacing first
and it gets much, much smaller.
It turns out that the energy is
some constant divided by n squared.
So the number one,
uh,
level has an energy of minus k.
The next one is minus one fourth k.
It's only the Blue Line is only uh,
only a fourth as far down as the green
from zero, which is up at the top. Is it?
Well it's the zero is that
gray line at the top right?
Cause it keeps going out to zero,
far out there.
And the next one is one
ninth of the way from,
from the top to the lowest level.
So the reward for finding side was the
knowledge of everything we've seen the
allowed to energy and structure.
Now we're going to see another case
where we get structure and we also see
something about dynamics that's
interesting about the motion of the atoms.
So here's suppose this is a high,
a proton attached to a bar by a
bond to something that's heavy.
So the other, the heavy thing doesn't
move. The hydrogen does the moving. Okay.
And here's it's wave function. This is
the re, this is the bond to distance.
The minimum energy. If you stretch
the bond, the energy goes up.
If you compress the bond,
the energy goes up.
And that's the way you function for
the position of the hydrogen atom
right
now. Suppose we increase the mass and
instead of talking about a hydrogen atom,
we talked about a carbon atom,
which had a say 14.
Okay. Depending on what isotope
we're using, suppose we went to 14.
How is that going to change things?
If we have mass it can we use the
same function? If we use mass of 14
notice that we're having,
we're using the same potential.
So the kinetic energy at any point
is going to be the same for the two.
How does mass enter into kinetic energy?
Yeah.
Yup. Okay. Here's,
why do you say it would be
more concentrated? What would
make it more constantly?
They're tired, so yeah,
but you're not thinking about
quantum mechanics. You're
thinking that the higher,
uh, well no, wait a second. We're
not talking nuclear charge here.
All we're talking to his mass. It's
held by a spring. We're thinking, okay,
so the electrostatics doesn't
come into it. It's a spring.
That's stretching Elizabeth,
please.
Yeah. The kinetic energy
has won over mass in it.
So if you increase the mass
and keep the same wave,
what are you going to do to the energy?
You're going to decrease the energy,
but it's the same energy
as it was for hydrogen.
You can't just decrease the energy right
at a given position if you know the
total. Okay. So you want it to be,
uh,
you want it to be,
to get the same energy,
it has to be more curved.
Okay. Everybody with me to
be, to have the same energy.
If you have a bigger
mass in the denominator,
you're going to have
to have more curvature,
14 times as much curvature to
compensate for the bigger mass.
So it's going to curve more
toward the baseline. Okay.
So if we use that same energy
and had the higher maths,
so we got more curvature
for the same energy,
then it's going to curve a lot more.
It's going to go through and
go up to infinity and it, it's,
it's even higher energy.
Then the second wave would be
it's curved way too much.
So how would you find the lowest energy?
What would you do in your guessing?
If you wanted to find the lowest energy,
what would you do?
You'd lower your guests to make it
less curved towards the baseline.
Okay. Then if you do that, so lower
the energy if your math and there,
we've got the answer right.
So hydrogen has a much higher vibrational
energy than carbon does for the same
bond to get the lowest energy.
Yeah.
I think this will be clear to you
when you have time to think about it.
If not,
ask questions right now.
What have you had you to 35 or a
marble at the end of the same spring?
What do you think gets wave
function would look like?
The lowest energy wave function,
it's just the spike. The heavier
it is, the narrower it yet, right?
So if you have something like the
baseball held by a bond, right?
It's going to sit right there.
You're not going to be able
to see that it's spread out.
Electrons are so much
lighter than the nuclei.
Electrons really spread out.
Okay?
Now.
So there are the probability distributions
for hydrogen and for carbon held by a
single bond. Why is their
average not in the same position?
See what I mean is acceleration.
Acceleration has to do with me.
Yes. No, it has to do. Yeah. You guys,
the electrodes are not attracted. No, no.
It's w remember electrons
aren't entering into this.
We're just supposing that
we have a nucleus held by
a spring and that spring is
the strength of a single bond.
Okay.
What's the potential?
What is the potential for a bond?
Is it Hooke's law?
What's a better potential for a bond
on Hooke's law? The Morris potential,
which broadens out,
remember as it goes up.
So since hydrogen goes up more,
it samples further out to the right.
So what's the splice to the right
from the, from the carbon. Okay.
Now,
so let's,
here they are at their minimum
energy position and they vibrate.
The higher energy has shifted to the
right and the unsymmetrical Morris
potential and that here's the
half maximum of the problem.
So it spends,
this is it's half as probable that the
probability density here is half what it
is there. So when you say how
far does it spread out? This,
this thing goes out to infinity, but we
can talk about how wide it is by say how,
why did, does it half height. So the
hydrogen had half height is from,
from here to here, uh, from,
from, from here to here.
But the carbon had half height is
only from there to there. That is,
if you think of these things vibrating,
the hydrogen has a bigger
amplitude than carbon
because it's lighter.
So the hydrogen vibrates by 0.1
on strum 9% of the distance,
the carbon vibrates only half as much.
3% of the carbon x distance.
Okay. Just because of the
mass difference. And never,
we said before last time that typically
the atoms are vibrating by about 0.05,
uh,
Armstrong's in the crystal.
That's where this came from is
this quantum mechanical thing.
That's the least that they can pop in
when they're in their lowest possible
energy state.
They vibrate by that much.
Right.
And that's how much it is.
That little yellow dot after it shrank.
So we've seen allowed energies
and structure. We've seen
dynamics, the vibration.
Now next time we're going to look at
dynamics and also the payoff bonding,
how we understand bonding,
and one dimension.